hey guys and welcome to episode number
23 of my road to one bill series today
we're gonna be focusing on only demons l
or we need 50 kills because we've been
working forces for a while and let's see
what the loot will be all right I was
actually a pretty good kill we're coming
in with a saradomin bruise and battle
stabs I was actually a really good loot
three minutes and 13 seconds and not bad
now this is my tenses Alric hill I did
lose some of the footage but um we're
going to do 40 more still and of course
we're still keeping track of loot just
not recording every single one we're we
go battle stabs and Zoeller skills at
175 K pretty decent all right we got
another kill coming in 2 minutes and 40
seconds is such as our quickest kill by
far I'm not sure how we act even got
that to be honest but a pretty bad loot
probably only worth maybe 50 K I've
noticed well mainly if you get snake
skin then your day just ruined because
the same skins and more as anything but
I mean this will still be 56 K isn't
awful again another very quick kill well
for me anyway 3 minutes is pretty good
I'm usually get in between 3 and 4
minutes so 3 is on the better end in
another very good loot
we got Brunei or as well as sharks I
believe as I should be 200k on top of
that and of course we got the solver
scale so 245 kata is probably our best
loop so far kill number 13 coming in I'm
gonna be pretty slow kill but we did
give a stab
so that would be a pretty possible kill
still 1010 battle stab sorry and at 1000
flax I'll be probably about 100k if I
were to guess 120 not bad
kill number 14 coming in with both raw
sharks and chaos rune so getting pretty
lucky here I think the average drop is
around 100 K but we're getting over 100
K pretty consistently right now 3
minutes pretty good kill time as well as
kill number 14
raw sharks are worth 80 K chaos rooms 51
and 150 K that's a really good loop
alright another kill come in and begin
the brunette or again that alone is
worth like 100 K almost I think each one
at over must be at least 10k
yeah brunette or is worth 123 kids drop
in blacks is worthless but so 150 K a
kill number 14
sorry come in with Xander teleport but
nothing really special
Sall undertale parts are worth about 40k
but the two blacks and solar skills will
probably make this a 72 70 kill and I
will be showing a full kill and once
I've done all this practice and we can
see where I'm at skill wise because you
can tell I'm getting kills and including
three and four minutes but we'll show
you fooling at the end oh man that was
an exceedingly close kill three minutes
and 27 seconds and we're getting battle
stabbed cast rooms as a pretty good loot
though the man there's been a couple
times where I've been down to five HP
with honestly no food left and poise and
economic so this was another one of
those close calls thousand ninety K
blower scales and chaos runes will be
worth behind 25k although the venom did
kick me of that all right now the kill
come in for raw sharks and Xander
teleport that's pretty good that is
another 125 K for her to guess it's
reckon stone come in on kill 20 ish
kappa weird draw by Dylan and Noah
that's a rare drop table or just a
random drop the silver has add yeah I
guess that's okay it's not really worse
a lot but I guess that's a well probably
a 50 or 60 K kills I'm not a whole lot
slower kills antidotes are worthless and
Dragon sounds worthless yeah it's pretty
bad kill and there it is guys the dragon
medal of course coming in with leat
amount of scales kind of yeah well I
mean it's still better than most drops
but if you know it's not really better
in most drops it kind of sucks looks
like this kill is worth just over honor
K Eric hill coming in and it's going to
be dranking bones 30 dragon bones that's
pretty nice and that alone must be where
the hundred K in the crystal seed dragon
bones are worth about 88 k and zeller
scales and in the crystal key have how
to be better actually
alright another kill come then with a
dragon bolt tips and lower scales and
the antidote
unfortunately antidotes are actually
pretty much worthless they're only worth
one or two K for the drop so and the
dragon bolt tips aren't actually worth
as much as I thought they'd be
I guess the Onyx ones are worth more and
only twelve K from that and lower scales
does kind of beast up a bit but still
pretty bad kill kill number twenty five
or twenty for coming in with Runa or
once again that is definitely one of
ours better
more common drops lunate or is worth 120
k and I've gotten it I think twice or
almost three times that
so we're net over 120 KS all our scales
like 30 K and was Col 54 cases at 200 K
kill kill number 25 coming in three
minute kills so pretty good we got under
emerald which I'm not sure if that's a
rare drop table or not I think soaks I
did not see an emerald on the drop table
normally all right kill number 26 was
kind of slow a but we did get an amazing
drop of Rouen eight or and magic seeds
that may be our most valuable killed so
far I'll go ahead and price check that
for you quickly I know they're going to
wear 120 KS on my mu magic seed is 138
in the lower scales making it almost a
300 K kill I definitely our best so far
and following up a pretty bad kill
unfortunately three minutes and 33
seconds is an awful but the loot is
pretty bad Calcott seeds and and today
aren't worth anything that's probably
only 30k kill number 28 coming in with
azo and your teleport and 40k from that
flax and lower scales are kind of met
it's probably a 50k kill kind of 2829 I
guess I rotate bar a singular Rene bar
so that's not the best that's only a K
from our pen K from that but still a new
drop in three minutes and 26 seconds is
pretty average but not too bad another
kill coming in at 3 minutes and 42
seconds
pretty slow on this lower end of
everything that they've killed so far
but we still not be our personal best of
two minutes and 40 seconds yet but still
it'll happen eventually kill number 31
coming in with Cole which walk to keep
track of because we were getting a lock
hole and death rune drop so they're
getting tossed into a regular tab but
let's to keep o in the law room forever
the LOB rings but anyway that's a
hundred can kill pretty nice kill number
32 coming in with a pretty shitty two
cup coconut in the papaya trees actually
are worth a good amount I thought it was
a cow quad papaya is our window so
papaya
okay I'm taking the palm tree seed okay
well coat that so we'll see how much it
worth if I see you don't want that much
never mind so 40 K kill pretty weak
somewhere just take in a minute I had to
do some work and edit
video so we decided use the well trained
a range up a level just AFK NAT name
Arizona and well I'm no expert include
the same here just one extra range level
will it's going to increase our time
dramatically I'm sure but nice to have
it anyway
oh right kill number 33 come in with
death runes and chaos runes pretty nice
in that's about 200k drop I think Castle
rings mean more is about 50k and death
runes or a 3 or each 30 times 300 is 90k
roughly let's see I see if I buy math is
currently 100 1k okay my bad hundred
seventy-one k though kill number 34
coming in with absolute trash thanks
again and pure I sense probably the
worst kill so far and oh is he actually
dead okay we're good kill number 35
coming in with a saradomin brew and
wrecking ball tips and Zeller scales
that's very nice and probably hundred K
kill and Sarah brews being worth the
most by far saradomin brews are worth
72k the drop not bad hundred thirteen
keen total is pretty easy
alright kill number 36 coming in with a
pure essence in baobabs kinda it's
always pretty consistently begin that
drop of some sort and three minutes and
25 seconds is a pretty average kill for
me hey we beat our best time by one
second I think it was on the range phase
both times I've got my best time so
clearly the range first phase is the
easiest for me
kill number 38 coming in with a dragon
ball tips and fighters he'd I'm not very
good kills but that's okay kill number
39 coming in with lower scales and
blacks and very good kill time 2 minutes
and 45 seconds is very good very bad
loot oh oh
Pierson's was in there too weird oh man
look at that 24k I was not even worth of
supplies all right got never kill coming
in and just barely got it there Pompey
seeds and coconut palm tree seed is
probably 45 K or so coconuts not worth a
whole lot well 50k for Pompey seed and
yeah that's not bad kill I guess ok kill
41 has a magic seed and a battle salve
drop which is really nice again it'll be
about 200k a pretty slow kill time
unfortunate
but ah let's see magic seeds are worth
138 K bow staff 98 245 K in total for
that job worth the time for sure alright
skill number 42 coming in with
catherines and death runes that'll be
worth another 100k which is really good
getting that job they seem to come in
packs for some reason but and love that
intentional or just I'm getting it that
way but that's another 180 K from runes
alone pretty well kill number 43 coming
in with is all our skills in tow flax
and not that great kill number 44 coming
in with brunette or which is really nice
and over scales and swamp targets first
time I got swamped are although I don't
think it's worth a whole lot talked in
their innate or swamped are is worth 12
K so I'm not very valuable Wow we've got
a thousand chaos runes as a drop I mean
that's pretty good
clearly with the drop table of 500 and
500 which makes sense because I think
I'm pretty much always getting three
drops I don't know if I've noticed a
time when I haven't of course this
counts as three drops they just combined
but yeah I'm pretty sure you hit the
drop table twice on top of seller scales
I believe another kill coming in with
adamantite bars in brunette or that's
actually really good will price check
that quickly but the adamantite bars I
think are must be to gauge maybe for a
night or slower scales in Eddy bars in
our words 200k is a lose not bad oh man
we had 5 HP finishing up that one
caverns and snakeskin kind of average
okay kill number 48 is going to be cast
rooms Dragon Ball tips and Zoeller
scales another pretty average loot but I
mean that's why the spots was good even
the average loot is worth well almost
100k second last loop is going to be a
torsional seat as well as tour soul and
that must be worth a get them out
because tour soul seeds are like 40k
each and the tour soul is 9k is 160 k
pretty good thanks torso alright guys so
I'm going to go ahead and kills our
afraid guys and you will see the entire
process and you can see where I'm at now
versus where I was last week with my
last row too until episode
and that can kind of look in pose
commentary on what I need to improve or
what I did well etc so of course I start
by running into the corner with mystic
might on start slapping zeller for as
much damage as I can right away this is
probably the most damage you're going to
get in one phase before she switches
around so it's definitely worth making
sure you get as much as you can
I've started drinking the anti-venom now
because you don't take any venom damage
until Zeller attacks you and I found
that if I drank it before I went in on
the boat I would actually run out of
feminine protection before the end of
which would cause me up to drink another
dose and kind of waste money so that
kind of has been a small modification
that has saved me a little bit on my
resource cost from now it looks like
we're doing the red phase and followed
by the green on the most eastern corner
which is probably my second most
favorite phase the blue phase first is
probably my least favorite now because I
don't know why you just end up taking so
much damage from that phase and just a
bunch of magic phases and you can't
actually dodge all that damage and you
tend to get stacked out with the minions
on that one a lot which I'm not sure
exactly why it just happens to me a lot
so the blowpipe damage is decent but I
think that is one thing I really need to
work on my range level and my range gear
and because it's not hitting a lot and
same with magic I could use some extra
magic levels it's really increase my
kill time but so far I haven't actually
made any to Grievous mistakes yet
switching it's been decent and making
sure I have the Rings of recoil on
because if the Rings of recoil break you
were kind of screwed and wasted a little
bit of damage there because I took too
much and had to eat wild and Solvers
still up and now we're switching over
here uh yeah no huge mistake I could get
a little bit on the clicked and making
sure I eat at the proper time XM wasted
a little bit of time even while the
snake is still attacking me but yeah so
it looks like from here we're gonna move
on to the jazz bass pretty soon and I
have gotten a lot better jazz the
Genesis a lot of [__] going on but you
really have to focus on switching your
prayers and you're going to die right
away if you don't switch to
properly so you have to focus on that
above everything else and make sure you
have enough prayer when you're going
into the jad phase because you're not
gonna have enough time to drink a prayer
potion that's pretty important I've
noticed because I have another prayer
doing a jazz days in that just
unfortunate and yeah so we're going to
kep for more hits in and then we kinda
have to run across here I'm not sure if
there's a better way to do this but I
don't think so and they're going to eat
up as much as we can and Zoe is pretty
much dead I had finally gotten okay big
mistake there got hit by the immunity
phase I may have actually almost [__]
me luckily it didn't hit me again but
yeah that was a mistake and declared one
earlier but beyond that the kill was
pretty decent and we still had enough
food left finish it off and another
prayer potion even so we weren't clearly
in a huge risk of dying but there we go
kill number 50 coming in with the kill
time of three minutes exactly so not bad
and magic vlogs and dollar skills so
pretty good drop drops worth 180 K so
now we'll go ahead and go back to our
bank and price check everything for you
guys and see how much money we're going
to get make from 50 kills okay so start
off with draw some chaos runes about 3k
roughly and all our death runes as well
because we did empty our death runes but
we didn't empty the caverns earlier okay
so here's our tab of solver loot we've
got the dragon bones not notice
unfortunately but we did get about 100
dragon bones I had 17 already and the
battle slabs fly under teleports 100 or
10,000 Zora scales grimy dwarfs and wolf
weed 200 magic logs see very many of
those surprisingly 3 magic seeds with
half of the key 30 saradomin brews and
600 coal and I drag med helm brunette or
sixty and a six canto flax and it one
brunette bar and then some other junk
will withdraw the I guess look at the
palm tree seeds oh but that's going to
be pretty much the majority of the money
just a couple things left there and yeah
we'll go ahead and price check this so
from 50 kills we're looking like we're
going to get about
five point four mil so about 100k per
kill that's pretty well in line with
what I thought it was going to be so
pretty happy with the result again we're
going to factor in the cost of all our
supplies of course and roughly this took
us five hours of course once we get
better at killing Zalora the speed will
get better but for now ten kills an hour
and 5.5 moment alright guys so sold off
all these lower leaves for about 5.2 mil
and again that did take us five hours
now as the cost of supplies I calculated
roughly about 40 to 50 K per kill hoping
to get that down with more experience
but that's going to take our amount and
cut it almost in half so let's say about
three mil of a truffle Hugh's profit so
three million five hours isn't awful but
not nearly as good as we like it to be
so of course we need to get higher
levels need to give better genre but it
was a lot of fun and really enjoyed
doing the boss for once and it was
pretty decent money hoping to get more
later so our bank is at about five point
two milks they have invested a lot of
time and money and resources into
getting those all requirements and
leveling up our account and we also have
some amulets we're going to use next
episode to string and get some our magic
experience we have another two mil or
three mil in that so we about eight mil
cash will have once everything is said
and done and it's not awful but we have
lost a lot of money but I thought I
would do a bit of a recap since you guys
were looking like you wanted it now four
skills are up to just 79 really big
change and only changes a lot I think so
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed and I
will see you guys at an episode number
[Music]
you